how do medical school electives work?
so electors are essentially a placement that you do
and organise yourself
at my uni, it's for 6 weeks,
but it can be 4 weeks,
6 weeks or 8 weeks depending on where you go.
normally that's like the range, but yeah,
so it's a place that you can do anywhere in the world
in most unis
in any specialty you like,
any department you like,
and it's often done in the last year
or the second to last year medical school.
so I can talk a little bit about my experiences.
but me and my friends are looking to go to
South America,
we've just sent those emails out to the places,
got in touch with those different agencies
and essentially trying to organise sort of a plan,
put our time out there
so we're liazing with all these organizations
and hospitals to try to sort that out on that side
and then with a uni,
there's just loads of forms that we need to fill into,
like a risk assessment form,
contact forms and itinerary form,
stuff like that.
so our electors
block is 8 weeks at
starting in April.
so, yeah, that's how it works.
that's how it works for us.
not sure about the unis, ha ha,